my name's Miles Morales I'm Spiderman
he's going to be here any minute give me
your money so are you like a cow or a
Dalmatian Spider-Man
there's bubbles now hold on
[Music]
I don't think I want this costume
anymore how's this going miles's grades
are pretty good A and AP Physics that's
my little man and a B in Spanish
miles
wanna get out of here no clown from the
spider Society I'm Spiderman oh no way
all of us are
Miguel O'Hara
moments in our stories that are the same
for all of us some good did you bring
our baby to another fight he asked me
not to so I didn't it's in bed you have
a choice between saving one person and
saving every world
I can do both all stations stop
Spiderman you know
[Music]
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go nah I'm gonna do my
own thing
because they get any weirder
I guess it can
there's nowhere to run
my bad everybody there was somewhere to
run June second this film does not get
ready